EYES, I REALIZED I MADE A BIG
MISTAKE.
>> Laura: BUT SHE WAS FOR THE
BEHEADINGS.
MEDIA OUTLETS HAVE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PAINTED A
SYMPATHETIC PICTURE OF THESE
TERRORIST BRIDES, NOW YEARNING
FOR THEIR HOMELANDS.
DO THEY HONESTLY WANT US TO FEEL
BAD FOR THESE WOMEN?
ONE OF THE WOMEN YOU JUST HEARD
FROM, ALABAMA NATIVE HODA
MUTHANA, IT IS NOT JUST
HAPPENING HERE, THE U.K. IS
DEALING WITH THE SAME PROBLEM.
PIERS MORGAN, EDITOR AT LARGE
FOR "THE DailyMail.com," YOU
SAID OF ONE OF THESE BRIDES
LOOKING TO COME BACK TO THE
U.K., THAT SHE SHOULD ROT IN
HELL.
TELL US HOW YOU REALLY FEEL.
I SEE HER GLIB RESPONSE TO A
QUESTION ABOUT BEHEADINGS, AND I
CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE WE ARE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION.
>> IT'S EXTRAORDINARY, ISN'T IT,
THAT WE'RE EVEN DEBATING THIS?
THIS IS A WOMAN WHO GOES OVER
THERE, MARY'S AND ISIS
TERRORIST, SUPPORTS AND ISIS
TERRORIST, BREEDS WITH THE
NICEST TERRORIST, FOR ALL
INTENTS AND PURPOSES HERSELF,
AND ISIS TERRORIST, ISN'T SHE?
SHE IS SUPPORTING THE ISIS
MOVEMENT, THE CALIPHATE, THE
DESIRE TO TAKE OVER THE WORLD
WITH THEIR BARBARISM, AND SHE
WITNESSES BEHEADINGS AND APPEARS
TO THINK THAT IS A GOOD TIME.
I TELL YOU WHAT, I DON'T AGREE
THAT THAT IS A GOOD TIME.
BEHEADINGS ARE DESPICABLE,
MEDIEVAL, BARBARIC, AND EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR HAS TO BE MADE
ACCOUNTABLE.
AS WE'VE JUST DISCOVERED IN
BRITAIN, THANK GOD, TONIGHT, THE
BRITISH UNDERSECRETARY, THE
EQUIVALENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
CHIEF IN BRITAIN, HAS REVOKED
HER CITIZENSHIP IN A CASE OF THE
ISIS WIFE WHO CAME FROM BRITAIN.
SHE WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED BACK IN
THE COUNTRY WITHOUT A MASSIVE
LEGAL FIGHT.
I HOPE AMERICA TAKES EXACTLY THE
SAME VIEWS OF THE AMERICAN ISIS
WIFE.
BY THE WAY, DIDN'T MARRY ONE
ISIS TERRORIST, SHE MARRIED
THREE OF THEM.
THREE ISIS TERRORIST.
I'M SORRY, LAURA, BUT TO ME,
THIS IS COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY
NUTS.
ANYONE IN AMERICA OR BRITAIN WHO
THINKS YOU SHOULD COME BACK.
>> Laura: COME BACK AND SPEND
ALL OF HIS MONEY LITIGATING
THEIR CASE SO SOME COURT
APPOINTED ATTORNEY FOR THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE TO PAY FOR,
ARGUES SOME COCKAMAMIE IDEA
ABOUT HOW SHE WAS OVER THERE,
YOU KNOW THAT IS WHAT THEY WOULD
ARGUE.
LEO SHOULD REVOKE THEIR
CITIZENSHIP, AS WELFARE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO COME BACK
HERE.
YOU WANT TO BE TAKEN CARE OF IN
THE MIDDLE EAST WHERE YOU ARE
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO GET THE
ACLU REPRESENTING YOU, THAT WAS
HER DECISION.
PIERS, I WANT TO PLAY ANOTHER
SNIPPET FROM THE ALABAMA ISIS
BRIDE, AND YOU WILL -- YOU WON'T
BELIEVE IT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> MAY BE THERAPY LESSONS, A
PROCESS THAT WILL ENSURE THAT WE
NEVER DO THIS AGAIN.
>> Laura: PIERS, SHE IS SAYING
SHE COULD REFORM HERSELF THROUGH
THERAPY LESSONS, INVARIABLY THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS WILL HAVE TO
PAY FOR THAT, TOO.
>> LET'S BE VERY CLEAR, THIS IS
THE SAME WOMAN WHO, ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THREE OR FOUR YEARS
AGO, BESEECHED EVERY MUSLIM IN
AMERICA TO RISE UP AND SPILL
AMERICAN BLOOD.
SHE PARTICULARLY WANTED TO DO IT
USING DRUGS TO SPILL AMERICAN
BLOOD.
TWO YEARS LATER, THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT SOMEBODY DID IN NEW YORK, A
RADICALIZED ISLAMIST IN NEW YORK
GOT INTO A TRUCK AND MOWED DOWN
AND KILLED A NUMBER OF INNOCENT
PEOPLE.
SHE WAS CRYING OUT FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN.
THAT BLOOD WAS SPILLED.
AND NOW SHE WANTS TO SAY, HEY,
I'M SORRY, I KNOW THAT THE ISIS
DREAM IN SYRIA IS OVER.
I KNOW THAT MY ISIS TERRORIST
HUSBANDS HAVE NOW BEEN KILLED,
AND I WANT TO COME HOME BECAUSE
I AM NOW A REFORMED CHARACTER.
I'M NOT BUYING ANY OF IT.
SHE WAS VERY SEVERELY
RADICALIZED, WHICH IS WHY SHE
WAS OUT THERE, WHY SHE STAYED
OUT THERE, WHY SHE HAD THE THREE
ISIS TERRORIST HUSBANDS, AND I
THINK SHE REMAINS A VERY CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO AMERICANS
AND TO AMERICAN LIVES.
>> Laura: AND KIDS, THEY'LL
HAVE KIDS.
THE KIDS COME BACK AND GO TO
AMERICAN SCHOOLS, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, YOU ARE OUT
IN L.A., ABOUT THE JUSSIE
SMOLLETT HOAX.
YOU ALREADY GET THE SENSE THAT
THE ENTERTAINMENT THAT HAS GONE
QUIET FOR THE MOST PART, SO WHY
ARE ALL OF THE HOLLYWOOD
ACTIVISTS WHO RUSHED INTO
CONDEMN THIS ATTACK, WHERE ARE
THEY?
WHERE IS ELLEN PAGE?
WHERE IS SHE?
>> LET'S BE CLEAR, LAURA, THEY
RUSHED IN FOR ONE REASON, THIS
LOOKS LIKE THE ABSOLUTELY
PERFECT STORM ANTI-TRUMP STORY,
DIDN'T IT?
IT WAS A COUPLE OF GUYS, A
COUPLE OF WHITE GUYS WEARING
"MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN" HATS,
WHO HAD LAUNCHED A DELIBERATE
AND SAVAGE ATTACK ON A GAY,
BLACK ACTOR, AND HAD DONE SO
BECAUSE THEY WERE PRO-TRUMP.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE NARRATIVE
THAT JUSSIE SMOLLETT HAD TOLD
EVERYBODY.
HE'S BEEN ON NATIONAL TELEVISION
TO REINFORCE THIS.
HE'S GIVEN A VERY CLEAR ACCOUNT
OF THIS APPALLING, RACIST,
HOMOPHOBIC ATTACK.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS IT LOOKS
LIKE -- I HESITATE TO JUMP IN
WITH COMPLETE CERTAINTY HERE,
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN A CRAZY
STORY, CHANGING ALMOST BY THE
HOUR -- BUT I THINK MOST
RATIONAL PEOPLE LOOKING AT THE
STORY NOW HAVE COME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT IT IS A LOAD OF
OLD HOGWASH.
THIS GUY HAS PROBABLY INVENTED
THE STORY.
IF THAT IS TRUE, IT IS HARD TO
IMAGINE --
>> Laura: WHERE ARE THE
HOLLYWOOD TYPES?
>> I TELL YOU WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY WANT THIS TO DISAPPEAR.
THEY WANT THIS TO HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED, BECAUSE THE MOMENT IT
LOOKED LIKE IT WAS WHAT JUSSIE
SMOLLETT TOLD US, THEY CAME, NO,
NO, NO, THIS IS THE WORST THING
EVER.
I WOULD NEVER HAPPENED, MOVE ON.